.
Ein Luzerner Unternehmer erlebt
das schwierigste Jahr seines Lebens.
Auch wenn man am Ende
der Kräfte ist, muss es weitergehen.
Und es geht auch weiter.
Corona setzt der Firma stark zu.
Eine Künstlerin hofft bis zuletzt,
dass sie auf Tournee gehen kann.
Ich glaube, die Menschen
freuen sich sehr darauf,
dass sich
die Vorhänge wieder öffnen.
Ein 50-jähriger Familienvater
steht vor einer unsicheren Zukunft.
Man wird arbeitslos.
Es ist ein Schock.
Zwei Hotelbetreiber lassen sich
von der Krise nicht entmutigen.
Wir glauben schon,
dass uns viele besuchen werden.
Jetzt gibt es wirklich
nur noch Vollgas vorwärts.
Ihre Geschichten
in "Luzern im Coronajahr".
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Luzern im Februar 2021.
Läden und Museen sind geschlossen.
Sogar die traditionelle
Luzerner Fasnacht muss ausfallen.
Das Jahr mit der Pandemie
hinterlässt Spuren.
Die Menschen werden coronamüde.
Roland Küng, der CEO
der Festzeltbaufirma Hunziker,
hatte im letzten Jahr einen Verlust
von 1,3 Mio. Fr. zu verkraften.
Hunziker gehört
zur Messerli Group in Wetzikon.
Der oberste Chef
hat Roland Küng einbestellt.
Andreas Messerli besitzt neun Firmen,
die auf Live- und Digitalanlässe
spezialisiert sind.
Online spricht er zu seinem Team
und drückt seine Begeisterung
über die Impfungen aus.
Das sind für unsere Branche
natürlich sehr gute Nachrichten.
Ab jetzt heisst es nämlich, dass
diese Pandemie ein Ablaufdatum hat.
Das ist klar.
Live is Life.
Das Leben findet live statt und
wir werden sehr stark zurückkommen.
Bleibt gesund! Wir sehen uns.
Vielen Dank!
Andreas Messerli gibt Roland Küng
einen Einblick
in die Messewelt der Zukunft.
Habt ihr das ... ähm ...
Das ist jetzt neu
unser Digital Lab ...
Ja.
... wo wir wirklich sehr viele
Kunden haben, die schauen kommen.
Hier geht es darum, wie man einen
Messebesuch der Zukunft machen kann.
Man kann ihn virtuell machen
mit diesen Tools.
Dann hat es einen Punkt ...
Bist du immer noch im Lift?
- Ja, ich bin im Lift.
Du solltest eine Holzplanke ...
- Ja, eine Holzplanke.
In welchem Stock bist du?
- Im 40. Stock.
Versuch, herauszukommen!
- Ich gehe nicht raus.
Doch, du schaffst das. Langsam.
- Das geht nicht.
Versuch es noch einmal!
- Oh!
* Lachen *
Ich gehe nicht raus. Fertig.
Es ist unglaublich, gell?
- Es ist brutal.
Wenn du nicht rausgehst,
kannst du es wieder wegnehmen.
Achtung, die Brille!
- Ja.
Das ist voll krass.
Da siehst du, wie intensiv
diese Virtual Reality ist.
Das muss man sicher sagen:
Das ist der grösste Unterschied
zwischen Messerli und Hunziker.
Wir betreiben zehn Firmen,
alle im Livecom-Bereich.
Den Zeltbau, die Zeltvermietung hat
es wirklich am härtesten getroffen.
Ihr könnt nicht
auf digital umstellen.
Ihr macht dieses Jahr 15 % Umsatz,
oder?
Ungefähr, ja.
- 15 bis 20 % Umsatz.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Quasi wegen eines Berufsverbots.
Und doch glaubt Messerli an Hunziker.
Wir suchten das Sommergeschäft
immer als Ergänzung.
Das haben wir mit Hunziker gefunden.
D.h., wir werden
ganz sicher alles machen,
damit Hunziker
wieder stark herauskommt.
Für uns ist das sehr wichtig,
für die Gruppe ist es wichtig,
weil sie ja fast systemrelevant
für diese Branche sind, oder?
Das hört man sehr gerne.
Es tut auch unheimlich gut,
wenn man das hört.
Das sind jeweils
die hoffnungsvollen Momente,
die dich auch wieder aufbauen
und in denen du weisst, warum du das
machst und warum du weitermachst.
In der Krise sieht Andreas Messerli
sogar seine grosse Chance.
Voilà!
Geht das mit dem Abstand?
- Ich denke schon.
Ja, ja. Genau.
Danke, gell!
- Bitte schön!
Was hörst du denn
von den Marktbegleitern?
Es ist ruhig. Es ist sehr ruhig.
Der eine oder andere hat Probleme.
Grössere, kleinere.
Ich schätze es so ein:
Wenn es im Frühling
nicht schlagartig losgeht ...
... sehe ich echt schwarz
für den einen oder anderen.
Und schlagartig losgehen ...
... wird es sicher nicht.
- Wird es sicher nicht.
Das sind ganz grosse Chancen,
weil wir in diesem Markt natürlich
der grosse Weissrücken sind.
Jeder, der aufhören will
oder jeder, der Kooperationen sucht,
kommt natürlich auf uns zu.
Das ist klar.
Wenn wir jetzt
die Gelegenheit haben,
diese Ausweitung in der Schweiz
hinzukriegen, prüfen wir das genau.
Ja, ja. Wie gesagt, den Winter
müssen wir jetzt noch überstehen.
Gegen den Spätfrühling hin
löst sich das dann schon.
Ich staune über deinen Optimismus,
Andreas.
Doch, doch.
- Der tut unheimlich gut.
Die Impfung wird viel verändern.
Das gibt dann
einfach diese Entlastung im Kopf.
Dann wird das Ganze wieder planbar.
Die Expansionspläne seines Chefs
machen Roland Küng neuen Mut.
Bojan Jovanovic
hat einen schweren Gang vor sich.
25 Jahre hatte er
beim Souvenirhändler Casagrande
als Hauswart gearbeitet.
Im Herbst erhielt er
wegen der Corona-Krise die Kündigung.
Jetzt muss sich der 50-Jährige
beim Arbeitsamt anmelden.
Zum ersten Mal in seinem Leben.
Grüezi!
- Grüezi, Jovanovic mein Name.
Grüezi, Herr Jovanovic.
Ich ... Man wird arbeitslos.
Das habe ich bereits vorbereitet.
- Vielen Dank!
Und, ähm ...
Wir machen hier
die Anmeldung beim RAV.
Wie lange waren Sie dort tätig?
25 Jahre.
- Beim gleichen Arbeitgeber?
Ja.
Und das Ausbildungsniveau?
Was haben Sie gelernt?
Ich habe Automonteur gelernt.
Danach machte ich
noch eine Handelsschule ...
... und absolvierte Englischkurse.
So kam ich dann
in die Tourismusbranche.
Okay.
In welchem Bereich
suchen Sie nun eine Stelle?
Das ist schwierig zu sagen.
Wir hatten auch Immobilien ...
... also Gebäude,
in denen ich sehr viel mit Mietern
und Immobilienbewirtschaftung ...
Muttersprache ist Deutsch.
Sprechen Sie noch andere Sprachen?
Serbisch, Serbokroatisch.
Sehr gut? Gut?
Sehr gut. Das ist
eigentlich die Muttersprache.
Okay.
- Englisch.
Englisch.
- Gut.
Ja ...
Also, dann habe ich
diese Anmeldung erfasst.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
- Es ist gut so weit.
Wenn sich Fragen stellen,
komme ich wieder.
Auf jeden Fall.
- Besten Dank!
Eine gute Zeit
und bleiben Sie gesund!
Danke gleichfalls.
Auf Wiedersehen!
* Schwermütige Musik *
Es braucht ein bisschen Zeit.
Man sieht, dass man immer mehr und
mehr in der Arbeitslosigkeit ist.
Das realisiert man
noch nicht so ganz.
Noch vor Kurzem war Bojan der all-
seits geschätzte Mann für alle Fälle.
Jetzt geht er
in eine ungewisse Zukunft.
Auf dem Seetalplatz in Emmenbrücke
steht die älteste Jahrmarktbude
der Schweiz.
Mit viel Hingabe und Herzblut
renovieren Claudia Kienzler
und ihr Team
das über 70-jährige Varieté-Theater.
Wind und Wetter
haben den Schildern arg zugesetzt.
Hier das alte.
Das ist das alte, defekte.
Mit viel Sorgfalt
hat Schriftenmaler Severin Meier
die nostalgischen Schilder
neu gemalt.
Diese verleihen der Bude
frischen Glanz.
Es ist super. Mega.
Gell, es funktioniert nebeneinander?
Das geht schon, oder?
Es funktioniert, auch wenn es ...
Es passt gut,
auch wenn es Alt und Neu ist.
Die Entscheidung war gut,
nicht auf alt zu machen.
Was ich noch sagen wollte:
Es ist cool, wir mussten Severin
nicht finden, er hat uns gefunden.
Du fährst manchmal hier vorbei
und hast das Theater gesehen.
Er sprach uns dann an,
ob wir einen Schreiner oder einen
Schriftenmaler brauchen würden.
Das war wie ein Wink oder so ein ...
Es ist schön, wenn jemand
mit Interesse kommt und sagt:
"Ich nehme mich dem an,
ich riskiere es auch."
In diesem Frühling
will die 40-Jährige
auf Schweizertournee gehen.
Aber aufgrund des schleppenden
Verlaufs der Pandemie ahnt sie,
dass sie ihren Plan
wohl nicht wird verwirklichen können.
Ja, es ist verrückt.
Man ist parat mit den Zelten,
mit der Infrastruktur.
Die Vorfreude, wegen der man
das Ganze macht und baut, wächst.
Die künstlerischen Ideen kommen,
die Sitzungen mit der Regie.
Gleichzeitig
schrumpft die Möglichkeit
oder die Vision, dass es
tatsächlich im April starten kann.
Anfang März 2021
öffnen in Luzern Museen und Läden.
Das Hauptgeschäft von Casagrande
ist nur am Wochenende offen.
Souvenirhändler Robert Casagrande
sieht,
wie sich das Bild der Altstadt
verändert hat.
Hier, wo Mietpreise teilweise schon
seit mehreren Jahren überhöht sind,
mussten
um die 20 Geschäfte schliessen.
Andere finden keine Mieter.
Corona hat diese Krise verstärkt.
Das ist natürlich die Gefahr.
In ein so grosses Geschäft
muss eine grosse Kette hineinkommen,
die solche Mietzinse bezahlen kann.
International sieht man
in jeder Stadt das Gleiche.
Luzern muss eine Nische sein
auf diesem Gebiet
und braucht Angebote,
wo man Sachen findet,
die man nicht überall findet.
Hier ist auch ein Laden,
der kürzlich frei wurde.
Früher hatten wir grosses Interesse,
diesen Laden zu übernehmen.
Der Vermieter
wollte ihn uns nie geben.
Das war ein bisschen schade.
Hier hat jemand
etwas Ähnliches gemacht,
wie wir
hier in unserem Laden machen.
Er dachte, dort wo Casagrande ist,
ist ein guter Platz.
Er hatte aber kaum Erfolg
und jetzt, mit Corona,
ging ihm offenbar das Geld aus,
sodass er schliessen musste.
Die Miete war doch ziemlich hoch.
Hallo, David!
- Hoi, Robert!
Wie geht es?
- Gut, danke. Dir auch?
Ja, ja, super.
Läuft bereits etwas heute Morgen?
Ja, es kamen bereits ein paar Leute.
Ich war noch nicht einmal parat.
Von jedem verkauften Kaffee
gehen 10 % der Einnahmen
an Casagrande für den Standplatz.
Wow!
Immer schön mit einem Herz drauf.
(Lachend) Ich unterstütze dich
und du unterstützt mich.
Das ist schön.
Wir helfen uns gegenseitig.
Genau.
* Sanfte Musik *
Eines ist kaputt.
Claudia Kienzler, die Geschäfts-
führerin des Varieté Caleidoskop,
bekommt tatkräftige Unterstützung
von ihrer Mutter Ursula.
Ursula Scherrer mag das
Bohemien-Ambiente auf dem Platz.
Doch das war nicht immer so.
Als du damit begonnen hast,
daran herumzustudieren,
dachte ich zuerst: "Du meine Güte!"
Ich fand nicht gleich:
"So cool, ein Zirkus!"
Oder: "So cool, ein Varieté!"
Es ist
schon nicht gerade meine Welt.
Aber ich verstand,
dass es einen faszinieren kann.
Ich war ja jeweils
sehr gerne an solchen Orten.
Als ich merkte,
wie ernst es Claudia ist,
fand ich,
dass sie das schon kann.
Das geht schon.
Dann bin ich dabei.
Diese Vorhänge wurden
schon im alten Varieté benutzt.
In ungezählten Arbeitsstunden
hat ihnen Claudias Mutter jetzt
zu einem neuen Auftritt verholfen.
Wenn die Vorhänge hängen,
oder wenn dieses Edle reinkommt,
wird es zum Theater.
Das ist cool.
Das ist so der Prozess,
bis die Kultur wieder einzieht
oder bis wieder gespielt wird,
mit Vorhängen, die eigentlich wenig
sind, sehr viel Charme zu schaffen.
Die roten
waren schon immer das Sorgenkind.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Es zieht es einfach oben mit, nicht?
Das ist nicht gut.
- Das ist gar nicht gut.
Das ist die geschlossene Kultur.
Immer, wenn ein Vorhang aufgeht,
ist klar ...
Ich bin nicht die Einzige ...
Ich glaube, die Menschen
freuen sich sehr darauf,
bis die Vorhänge wieder aufgehen.
Wir wollen diesen Moment nutzen
und dann parat sein
mit den
zur Verfügung stehenden Mitteln.
Auftritt Chrigu!
- Auftritt Chrigu!
* Lachen *
Jetzt blinzelt noch die Sonne rein.
So schön!
Nicht weit vom Varieté entfernt
ist das Zuhause von Bojan Jovanovic
und seiner Familie.
Noch vor wenigen Monaten
hatte er einen 100-%-Job.
Jetzt muss er
seine Tage neu strukturieren.
Die Corona-Thematik treibt ihn um.
(Kommentar Handyvideo)
Das treibt die Skeptiker
vielleicht sogar in die Verweigerung.
Ja, man versucht ...
Ich schalte das mal aus.
Man informiert sich,
sammelt sehr viele Informationen ...
... liest ...
Beschäftigungsprogramm,
um sich selbst zu finden.
Der entlassene Hauswart
ist auf Sinnsuche.
Das Spirituelle hat viel mehr Wert
als das Materielle.
Das haben wir leider
mit der Zeit vergessen.
Und, ähm ...
Mit Materiellem versuchen wir,
das Spirituelle wiederzufinden.
Aber ja ...
Es hat geklingelt. Mal schauen.
Ist das alles?
- Ja, ich denke schon.
Merci!
Die Post ist da.
Bojans Töchter mögen das Materielle.
Das ist jetzt ...
Ich habe zwei Töchter,
die studieren.
Sie bestellen sehr gerne
Sachen über das Internet.
Zalando oder was auch immer.
Und, ähm, ja ...
Das war jetzt
ein Paket für die Tochter.
Bojan nimmt es gelassen.
PKZ - Papa kann zahlen.
Seit Anfang Jahr
sucht er nach einer neuen Stelle.
Doch der 50-jährige Allrounder ohne
Diplom muss schmerzlich erkennen,
dass seine Chancen begrenzt sind.
"Technischer Hauswart".
"Vielseitige Funktionen".
Für mich ist es
ein etwas böses Erwachen, weil ...
... es nicht so ist,
wie man es sich vorgestellt hat.
Sie suchen meistens gelernte Leute.
Ich habe Automonteur gelernt.
Das war vor 30 Jahren.
Und, ähm ...
Aber eben, weitergebildet
habe ich mich bei Casagrande,
also in der alten Firma.
Den Lebenslauf
musste ich auch zweimal anpassen.
Ich hoffe, dass es jetzt gut ist.
Bis jetzt kommen meistens Absagen.
Schriftlich oder elektronisch.
Hallo!
Mit Nina
ist Bojan seit 27 Jahren verheiratet.
Sie arbeitet Teilzeit
als Verkäuferin.
Bist du am Arbeiten?
- Ich bin am Arbeiten.
Bei mir sieht es so aus,
dass ich nun zu 40 % angestellt bin.
Vor zwei Jahren
hatte ich Rückenprobleme.
Im Moment arbeite ich viel weniger.
Deswegen wurde das bei mir
etwas reduziert.
So.
Jetzt gibt es
erst einmal einen Kaffee.
Dass ihr Mann in dieser
wirtschaftlich angespannten Zeit
keinen Job hat, belastet Nina.
Er ist jetzt viel mehr zu Hause.
Nervt ein bisschen.
Nein, nein.
- Nur ein bisschen.
Aber das geht doch allen gleich.
Es macht schon Angst ...
... weil es nie aufhört.
V.a. jetzt mit der Corona-Situation,
in der die Leute ihren Job
verlieren, also nicht nur Bojan.
Viele haben Existenzprobleme.
Das ist sehr schlimm.
Irgendwie ...
Wir versuchen, positiv zu bleiben.
Man denkt, es gehe schon vorbei.
Aber auf der anderen Seite
siehst du irgendwie kein Licht.
Es hört nicht auf.
Sali, du!
* Sanfte Musik *
Das mag er.
Wer nicht?
* Lachen *
* Beschwingte Musik *
Der Grendel war vor Corona
der Hotspot des Luzerner Tourismus.
Trotz guter Lage
hat das Luxusgeschäft,
das zum Casagrande-Imperium gehört,
fast keine Kundschaft.
Doch heute erwartet Robert Casagrande
eine Überraschung.
Müsst ihr kürzen?
- Nein, nein, einfach ...
Jawohl!
Ja, es ist ein Kunde hier,
der eine schöne Uhr gekauft hat.
Aber es ist bereits abgeschlossen.
Das ist
ein schöner Start in den Tag.
Solche einträglichen Verkäufe
sind viel zu selten,
darum gibt es
ein Corona-Alternativprogramm.
Im Boudoir für luxuriöse Spieluhren
werden jetzt
Gesichtsbehandlungen angeboten.
Man kann sich vorstellen, man liegt
hier auf dem Stuhl, wird behandelt
und eine Musikdose spielt.
Das ist ein einmaliges Erlebnis.
Aber zu wenig lukrativ.
Fast alle 100 Mitarbeitenden
sind in Kurzarbeit.
Die anderen
versucht der Patron aufzumuntern.
Wir hoffen, dass es doch ein paar
Leute gibt, die in Europa reisen,
die sich trauen,
bei uns hereinzukommen.
Daher werden wir
über Ostern voll geöffnet haben.
Heute ging es ja gut los.
Ich hoffe,
dass es heute weiterhin so läuft,
damit wir einen guten Tag haben
und uns alle freuen können.
Wir drücken die Daumen.
- Okay, vielen Dank!
Danke Ihnen.
Ich bin überzeugt,
dass Ende Sommer, Anfang Herbst
die ersten Leute kommen werden.
Individuell.
Aber es wird natürlich
drei bis vier Jahre dauern,
bis wir wieder
bei ähnlichen Zahlen sind wie zuvor.
Aus diesem Grund sind wir
natürlich sehr darauf angewiesen,
dass uns der Staat
in dieser Übergangszeit hilft.
Casagrande will,
dass das Familienunternehmen
auch in dritter Generation
weitergeführt werden kann.
Mit dem schönen Wetter
über die Ostertage
gönnen sich die Menschen
eine Auszeit.
Das Hotel Beau Séjour
ist aus dem Winterschlaf erwacht.
Eineinhalb Monate war es geschlossen.
Manuel Berger und Walter Willimann
inspizieren
die vergrösserte Terrasse.
Zusammen mit dem Besitzer haben sie
sie im Winter eigenhändig umgebaut.
Rein vom Design her
sind wir mega happy.
Wir transportieren genau das,
was wir uns vorgestellt haben.
Was wir noch nicht wissen, ist,
wie viele Leute kommen werden.
Summa summarum
bin ich sehr glücklich mit dem Lido.
Man muss mal diesen Raum anschauen.
Es ist eine halbe Turnhalle,
die zuvor nicht genutzt wurde.
Ja, so ist es.
Über die Ostertage
sind alle 28 Zimmer ausgebucht.
Diese Gäste
sind in Genf wohnhafte Expats.
Wo steht ihr Auto jetzt?
- Gleich über die Strasse.
Wir haben einen Parkplatz für Sie.
Wieso kamen wir nach Luzern?
Wir haben frei
und wir wollten eine Auszeit.
Wieso ausgerechnet Luzern?
Wegen der Museen
und dem sonnigen Strand.
* Lachen *
Wir wohnen direkt neben dem Strand.
Eine Tasse Tee, bitte! Schwarztee.
Aber auch Gäste aus Luzern freuen
sich über einen Tapetenwechsel.
Wir sind Wiederholungstäter
und -täterinnen. Wir lieben es hier.
Wir sind bestimmt
schon zum sechsten Mal hier.
Innerhalb eines Jahres.
* Lachen *
Es ist jedes Mal ein Erlebnis.
Wir haben
jedes Mal ein anderes Zimmer.
Wir sind jeweils gespannt,
welches wir haben.
Danke! Bis später.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Dieses haben wir zum ersten Mal.
Yeah!
Mit Balkon.
So schön!
- Mega!
Woah!
Seht ihr das?
Wow, so schön!
Herrlich!
Mega.
Sehr schön!
* Sanfte Musik *
Endlich wieder Arbeit.
Der Hoteldirektor
steht gleich selbst in der Küche.
Man spürt schon
eine Tendenz bei den Leuten.
Sie wollen wieder raus
und sie wollen buchen, trotz Corona.
Im Moment ist es sehr erfreulich.
Im Moment halte ich es so:
Wir nehmen alles, was geht.
Wir freuen uns über alle Gäste,
die kommen.
Aber was in nächster Zeit kommt,
können wir nicht sagen.
Nach vielen Höhen und Tiefen
im letzten Jahr
hat Manuel
den Glauben zurückgewonnen,
dass das Hotel Beau Séjour
eine Zukunft hat.
* Sanfte Musik *
Im Frühling mit dem Varieté
Caleidoskop auf Tournee gehen,
das war der Herzenswunsch
von Claudia Kienzler
und ihrem Freund Christoph Spielmann.
Doch daraus wird leider nichts.
Im Februar mussten wir entscheiden,
dass wir unter diesen Umständen mit
den Proben nicht starten konnten.
Wir haben die Tournee
auf nächstes Jahr verschoben.
Das sind
extrem schwierige Entscheide.
Parat sein wollen,
aber nicht wissen wofür.
Machst du die Tür auf? Yes!
Danke schön!
Trotz der grossen Enttäuschung
arbeiten die beiden
weiter am Bühnenprogramm.
Aber Einnahmen
wird es auch künftig keine geben.
Ausfallentschädigungen sind ungewiss.
Das ist Druck, den ich
in der Nacht und am Morgen spüre.
Und immer wieder.
Es gibt mir aber auch Energie,
weil wir merken wieder, wie wir hier
drin proben und etwas machen können
und dass es leben kann.
Wir haben ein Crowdfunding am Start,
das bis Ende Mai läuft.
Damit wollen wir die Gelder
für die restlichen Investitionen,
also für den Finish, generieren.
Und auch, um das Jahr
ohne Einnahmen überleben zu können.
So hält Claudia am Traum
vom fahrenden Jahrmarkttheater fest.
Äh, der ist noch nicht koordiniert.
Artistik, Musik und Kulinarik
als Gegenprogramm zur Welt draussen,
die wacklig und unsicher ist ...
... und wo immer wieder
der Absturz droht.
Jetzt hat es geklappt.
- Jetzt.
Die Idealvorstellung ist,
dass wir dieses Jahr doch noch
ein Varieté im kleinen Format,
also quasi ein Amuse-Bouche,
hier vor Ort durchführen können.
Noch idealer wäre fahren,
aber das sehe ich nicht.
Die Horrorvorstellung
oder die schlechteste Variante ist,
dass wir aufgeben müssen.
Ja.
An bester Lage direkt am See liegt
das Viersternehotel Kastanienbaum.
Hier macht Bojan Jovanovic
ein Praktikum,
das er vom RAV
zugewiesen bekommen hat.
Bei der Deckenbeleuchtung
muss unbedingt etwas gemacht werden.
Der Trafo vorne ist,
seit ich aus dem Militär zurück bin,
anscheinend ganz durch. Es flackert.
Vielleicht siehst du es.
Das Hotel war lange Zeit geschlossen.
Das hat Spuren hinterlassen.
Dieser Trafo hat wirklich Mühe.
Der neue Direktor Jonas Debbabi
führt Bojan
am ersten Arbeitstag durchs Haus.
Hier kommst du
mit dem roten Schlüssel rein.
Die Tische sind
noch nicht sauber abgeschliffen.
D.h., wir müssen das nochmals machen
und nochmals ölen.
Im zweiten und dritten Stock
ist z.B. noch gar nichts gemacht.
Wie ist es mit den Kühlschränken?
Haben sie eine Belüftung?
Genau, richtig.
Deshalb sind sie regelmässig defekt.
Das ist auch ein Thema,
das wir zusammen angehen müssen.
Ein nächstes grosses Thema
wird das Dach sein,
das wir reinigen müssen.
Da hätte ich
dann gerne noch deine Fachexpertise.
Was du von dem Dach hältst,
ob es dicht ist oder nicht.
Es hat schon Risse.
Es hat schon Risse
und es hat geflickte Stellen.
Es ist für die Techniker
eine neverending Story.
Sobald etwas erledigt ist,
kommt bereits das Nächste.
Es gibt sehr viel zu tun.
Der ganze Aufgabenbereich
muss natürlich zuerst einmal
ein bisschen zusammengefasst ...
... durchstudiert werden.
Aber, ja, es ist sehr interessant.
Zeitlich sind wir perfekt. Gut.
Im Keller
ist Bojans künftige Werkstatt.
Die Sachen der Badezimmer
wurden hierhergebracht.
Alle Spiegel und die alten
Wandhalterungen sind nun hier.
Ein grosses Chaos.
Deine Werkstatt ist dort hinten.
Die habe ich dir bereits gezeigt.
Kein Vergleich zu Bojans
früherem Arbeitsplatz bei Casagrande.
Ja ...
- Es fehlt noch ein bisschen etwas.
Man muss es
auf jeden Fall wieder komplettieren.
Aber jeweils nur das,
was gerade gebraucht wird.
Hier wird die Werkstatt sein,
d.h., hier muss Ordnung herrschen,
damit wir arbeiten können.
Das Lager ist dann hier, sobald
die Sachen hier weggeräumt sind.
Das ist dann dein Job.
- Ja.
Das ist
sehr, sehr, sehr viel Arbeit.
Ja, das ist viel Arbeit. Das ist so.
- Okay.
Bene?
Nach dem Rundgang ist der Direktor
überzeugt vom Mann für alle Fälle.
Herrlich! Besten Dank!
Er bringt natürlich schon
viele spannende Inputs.
Das hat man
während der Führung gemerkt.
Ihm stossen Sachen ins Auge,
die ich persönlich übersehen
oder denen ich keine Bedeutung
beigemessen habe.
Das finde ich
sehr gut und sehr spannend.
Daher glaube ich,
dass er der richtige Mann ist,
um das Ganze deichseln zu können.
Ich denke, das kriege ich hin.
Das ist nicht so ein ...
... Problem. Vor Arbeit
habe ich mich nie gescheut.
Und, ähm ...
Eben, wie gesagt:
Was sind die Prioritäten?
Ja, es braucht ein bisschen Zeit.
Schmutzige Gläser kommen
übrigens gleich hier in die Spüle.
Vielleicht
ist es nicht Bojans Traumjob,
aber immerhin ist er
auf dem Arbeitsmarkt wieder gefragt.
In Ibach bei Luzern bereiten Bagger
den Boden für ein neues Projekt vor.
Ein Provisorium im Rahmen
eines Umbaus des Kantonsspitals.
Der Auftrag geht an die Firma
Hunziker aus Willisau.
Das motiviert CEO Roland Küng
und seinen Projektleiter.
Weisst du ungefähr, wo es reinkommt?
Ja, dort hinten, wo jetzt ...
- Hier, oder?
Hier wäre eigentlich im Prinzip ...
Die Zufahrt wäre so: Man kommt
hinten durch und geht so wieder weg.
Schlussendlich.
- Okay.
Heute habe ich
die Brandschutztüren erhalten.
Dieser Auftrag hier
ist ein Provisorium für den
Rettungsdienst 144, Kanton Luzern.
Für uns ist er
natürlich sehr, sehr interessant,
weil er in einer Zeit kommt,
in der er für uns
ein grösserer Auftrag ist
und doch ein paar Leute wieder etwa
zweieinhalb Wochen arbeiten können.
Das ist natürlich sehr, sehr gut.
Es ist halt nicht Event.
Wir leben stark vom Event.
Es gibt wieder Hoffnung,
aber auf der Schiene,
auf der ich es gerne hätte,
ist halt nach wie vor nichts.
Ist es gut?
- Ja, es ist gut.
Dann gehen wir.
* Sanfte Musik *
Das 86-jährige Unternehmen
ist in einem historischen Tief.
Weil es
nicht behördlich geschlossen wurde,
hat es ausser COVID-Kredit
und Kurzarbeitzuschüssen
erst jetzt Härtefallgelder erhalten,
obwohl der Umsatz
um 85 % eingebrochen ist.
Ein hartes Jahr für Roland Küng.
Mein Jobprofil
wurde vom Geschäftsführer
zum klaren Krisenmanager,
zum Personalvermittler,
der versucht,
die Leute irgendwo unterzubringen.
Um Akquisen zu machen -
und zwar nicht in unserem Business.
Man versucht bei völlig fremden
Sachen Aufträge reinzuholen.
Ich denke, Hauptaufgabe ist, obschon
es nicht immer einfach fällt,
Motivator zu sein,
die Fahne zu packen, vorauszugehen,
die Leute mitzuziehen
und ein Zeichen zu geben,
dass es weitergeht.
Und so werden die Blachen wohl
noch lange in der Lagerhalle bleiben.
Bis im Frühling 2022 sei es für
seine Branche gelaufen, sagt Küng.
Aber der Unternehmer gibt nicht auf.
Roland Küng bleibt als CEO
bei der Firma Hunziker AG
bis es sie nicht mehr gibt.
Oder er wird pensioniert.
Ein Jahr wie kein anderes
liegt hinter uns.
Jede und jeder hat einen eigenen Weg
durch die Krise finden müssen.
Dabei wurden wir alle
mit der Frage konfrontiert,
was wirklich wichtig ist im Leben.
Ich versuche, mich nicht
ins Schneckenhaus zurückzuziehen.
Und, ähm ...
Eigentlich bin ich zufrieden,
wie ich diese Zeit meistern durfte,
weil ich mir absolut bewusst bin,
dass es mir viel besser geht
als manch anderem auf dieser Welt.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
In diesem Jahr habe ich gelernt,
wie stark man auf sich selber
gestellt und angewiesen ist.
Es kommt niemand, um einem zu helfen
oder um etwas zu machen.
Schlussendlich musst du
für dich da sein und weiterschauen.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Man hat eine wunderbare Partnerin,
man hat Geschäftspartner und ...
Ja, mit viel Tapferkeit an eine
Zukunft glauben und vorwärtsmachen.
Ich persönlich
habe das noch nie erlebt,
dass geschäftlich
etwas so komplett schwierig läuft.
Und, ähm ...
Ich persönlich nehme mit,
dass man in Zukunft
gewisse Sachen vielleicht
etwas lockerer sehen kann.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Ich persönlich nehme
einen riesigen Erfahrungsschatz mit
aus diesem Jahr,
dass ich den Grundoptimismus
und den Schwung behalte,
auch wenn es
immer mal wieder drückt.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Am Morgen klingelt der Wecker
und dann kommt die Verantwortung,
als Unternehmer hinzustehen
und mit allen Mitarbeitern und dem
Unternehmen in die Zukunft zu gehen.
Dann wird wieder gekämpft
und gefightet - wie ein Löwe halt.
Und so heisst es auch weiterhin
in Luzern und anderswo:
durchhalten
und die Hoffnung nicht aufgeben.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021